big
short investor michael bury says that
the tesla boom is remarkably similar to
the dot-com
and housing bubbles the hype around
tesla reminds michael bury
of the dot-com bubble of the late 1990s
and the housing bubble
of the mid 2000s he said in a tweet the
scion asset
management boss who has been a vocal
critic of tesla for several months
revealed in december that he was short
on elon musk's company tesla tesla stock
price has rocketed
more than 800 since the start of 2020
lifting its market cap
to north of 780 billion
of the idea that tesla's lofty stock
prices are self-fulfilling
because the business can issue shares to
fund its growth
bury said saw this same thesis many
times while partying in 1999. that's
what burries said
can you pull up a picture of michael
bury and then also of christian bale the
character he played in the big short
thank you mario
he says michael berry says the last big
short got bigger and bigger and bigger
too he said in another tweet
enjoy it while it lasts he says finally
what do tesla
bitcoin and option gamma traders have in
common
it rhymes with rubble
like barney rubble that's bubble so
here's a picture of
michael bury and the character he played
in the big short um
the sandal warren flip-flop you know guy
uh christian bale great actor by the way
but basically michael berry who does not
give interviews
he's does he's not really out there on
the scene over the last few months he's
like
all over the news these days going
against elon going against apparently
bitcoin
but he's betting against musk would you
bet against musk at this point i wonder
if he was playing the drums when he did
that wasn't he doing that in the movie
all the time
frantic energy with this guy by the way
you know how much he made not
from the movie or from the but but
actually from the big short from
shorting the housing
how many billion no he personally made
100 million
his investors made 700 million so i
thought it would be more than that too i
thought he was walking away with
billions in that thing when you watch it
in the movie
um i don't know you know he let's just
say this for me
everything you know in life is
scoreboard have you done something
before do you have credibility
this guy had some serious credibility
for what he saw that no one else wanted
to see
and clearly i think smart people they
were making so much money during that
housing bubble they wanted to ignore it
maybe in the back of their mind
um there were so many great movies about
the the
market crash and just the financial
crisis of 2008
man they're unbelievable but and that
was one of them so i i think you have to
pay attention to this i
i don't think you just like throw it
aside like this guy's a quack i don't
think you have to like take it
and say this is gonna happen in a few
weeks it'll be interesting
to monitor because that is an abnormal
spike in a stock price number one
number two their sales probably don't
justify that type of thing
um there's other there's gonna be a lot
more competition to tesla
so i think it's interest for a guy that
stays under the radar screen as much as
burry does he doesn't like detention
like this even though they made a movie
about his life and everything but you
don't
hear about him every day for him to come
out this aggressively
makes you just wonder is is he obsessed
with this like he was the housing
crash and maybe he does have some
information but then
you're battling two extremely smart guys
elon musk might
already be one step ahead of him and i
think maybe that's the way i might be
leaning
that elon musk is no um you know
fly-by-night guy that just happened
proven himself so i think i would be
leaning towards you know if it does take
a little dip it's
not going to hurt anything burrie versus
musk on the on tesla going long or short
who you get i just say
big short of the housing bubble versus
tesla stock price
it's not going to be the same thing it's
going to dip no question about it he's
probably got something to this
but i don't see this thing completely
going under like like uh
like you're doing you have a different
opinion on this guy uh i think it all
depends on how
long is the time frame we're looking at
how long is how far out are we looking
because
i think obviously if you look at the
stock it's it's gone like a hockey stick
it's gone straight up in 2020.
even even
elon musk tweeted at one point i think
this the stock price is too high in my
opinion
yeah uh so so and burry said something
about it's going to get crushed like a
souffle
yeah so i think that was like the first
quote that he came out with a couple
months ago
so so definitely sledgehammer honestly
no yeah
that's what elon said oh that's what
elon said and then okay then
brewery came out something about chamber
so that's right so uh so no so i think
that
obviously it's the but justifying if you
look at the earnings if you look at the
cars they're producing and the value of
the company
like it just doesn't match up so so a
lot of it i think is is hype stock in
the sense that they're just
on projecting on future earnings which
to one extent like obviously
tesla's been groundbreaking but i don't
see it being that crazy
um especially go ahead no especially
considering
a lot of what they did in the early on
is a lot of the patents for the cars are
open
um with meaning and volkswagen or anyone
can go in and borrow the patents and and
implement the technology in their cars
as well because elon musk's main vision
when he started tesla wasn't to create
the biggest car company in the world
it was to start the transition from
fossil fuel to battery
and i think we can all agree seeing by
2030 range rovers done with
electrical with gas vehicles
so i think we can all agree that he's
won no he could stop right now mission
accomplished
that exactly there's no going back we're
not suddenly five years we're gonna
from now gonna be like ah screw
electrical vehicles we tried that it was
a fad
thing we're going to have change change
exactly right i mean very powerful words
right there just like we talked about
with the uh synthetic beef
just like we talked about the electrics
yeah and everything everything yeah so
i mean listen here's my here's my two
cents right here the
the in the 90s what you were you born
bro
98 98 ridiculous ridiculous i was
graduating in high school at that point
um he wasn't even alive he wasn't even
alive
for the last dance of michael jordan you
weren't even alive you weren't even
alive the last time michael did that
that's like us watching something on
world war one when you're looking at the
last dance that's so secular i have an
appointment on this adam i haven't
appeared yeah well let me finish my
point here and then
i'll switch over to you the the dot-com
bubble if you had any company that just
ended with dot com people were willing
to give you millions and millions of
dollars like
anymore cuban yeah broadcasting.com
anything.com.com so
it was a house of cards same with
literally the housing market
in 2008 there was just a lot of bad
fake mortgages unqualified you know no
uh
asset no income all that nonsense
so he's comparing tesla the price of
tesla to two basically house of cards i
think it's fair to this say
maybe tesla its price is a little
overvalued
but the company is not a house of cards
so i think it's an unfair analogy right
there so
i understand that the comparisons he's
you know for someone who doesn't want
his name in the news
he's putting himself out there he's
drawing that analogy right there
so will tesla go down kind of like what
you said how long what's the time rise
in there yeah it might go down
but the backbone of the company and the
idea and the leader of the company
clearly is on the right side let me ask
you guys a question
or mario you do your point then i'll
throw a question because my question is
what if elon said
i want to put more time into spacex into
digging tunnels
and he stepped away from tesla what
would that do to the stock price if he
wasn't day to day
and he backed off a little i think that
would be bigger than anything probably
well he's propping up a lot of companies
just by tweeting stuff so yeah i mean if
you step down like kind of like how gate
stepped down i'm sorry uh
bezos stepped down from amazon what
would happen to the stock price at tesla
mario
no uh somebody in the comments and i
lost it so many comments on there but i
agree with adam in the sense because
it there are very different scenarios
there are different companies in the
sense but
the keywords for me are remarkably
similar but similar in terms of what
he's seen in the economy market
what's not similar to me is the
individual and i don't like to bet
against a visionary you know i wouldn't
bet against an elon because we've seen
his character
and i'll never forget the quote i've
heard about if you want to test a man's
uh character give him power well elon
musk is sitting on some
pretty big checks right now he's sitting
with a lot of power what are we watching
him do
right so that's that part of it the
other part is um you're right with the
housing stuff you had a lot of fraud you
had a lot of crappy leaders you had some
executives at the top they're just
dirty the kind of people that you don't
want leading companies and they destroy
the market at that point
i agree you know i do think elon is kind
of like that tony stark individual so
i wouldn't bet against uh you're saying
you're saying to your other point
money doesn't change you money exposes
who you really are
it enhances who you already are exactly
yeah exactly by the way best movie to
watch
on the housing crash and just the whole
2008 financial meltdown is margin call
have you ever seen that movie
the cast in that movie is so phenomenal
demi moore
um jeremy irons uh kevin spacey
kevin kevin space it is a phenomenal
movie
everybody if you haven't seen that one
check that out so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye